did you take it personally at the time
when when when the band started out and
like a guy like kurt cobain would
publicly
dismiss your band and say you guys were
too commercial or too pop or whatever
the [ __ ] he said
you guys ended up being friends and
everything and he ended up appreciating
you of course
did that [ __ ] get to you at the time
were you like why is everybody gotta be
so goddamn competitive
i probably could have agreed with some
of the things he said and there was also
a history of
you know some of the local bands and
one of my favorite seattle bands was mud
honey and and there was a little bit of
a faction of this this
one side of seattle music here and and
ours didn't fit as well into that
which was fine but also
mud honey i was so grateful to have
those guys as friends and so
i think the only thing that bothered me
about that was because it was
it was more public and people reacting
to it you know i it wasn't
like between us or that stuff wasn't
really going back and forth with
us and i think there was a certain
writer who
kind of pulled a quote of jeff aments
out and then pulled a code
a quote of kurtz out and then kind of
you know that made for interesting
press but you know really i always felt
like
it was kind of us against the world like
our town against the world not not our
band against another band we were
just i still think back and and have
always been grateful that there was like
a real scene i mean it was like a real
there was music everywhere and people
were hanging out like
you know every night and after the show
at the crocodile when three or four
bands would play in girl trouble in the
melvins and
da-da-da and then there'd be like an
after party in someone's
basement and this cool old house you
know in seattle
that was gonna ram shackle and then all
of a sudden you know chris novosel
should be playing bass and you know i'd
be playing drums there's
you know and we're playing beatles songs
and this guy you know fastbacks kurt
block
playing it was really one of those times